this is future vision this is the second
episode I saw apparently Cartoon Network
was running them in the correct order um
this is the one where kind of reveals
that she can see all sorts of various
possibilities for the future and that
she uses a lot to protect Steven Steven
freaks out and this is pretty much
almost gets himself kind of turns it
into a self-fulfilling prophecy I guess
yeah and then go and go on the roof so
he goes on the roof yeah and garner
realizes that by doing so she's creating
even more danger for him so all I kind
of remember when I saw this originally
was like I don't know who this kid is
but man is he having an existential
crisis and when they did the reveal of
her taking off the sunglasses I thought
that was supposed to be a big reveal I
was like whoa that's cool she's got
three eyes or whatever
I didn't realize like when I watched it
with you like from the beginning that
they would just reveal that in an
earlier episode yeah so when they did it
there was like oh that's like it's one
of the episodes I saw they revealed as
well and I thought same thing like oh
what's that like a big reveal it's like
oh and then you see it's revealed in the
video game ham episode um but uh two
things that jumped in mind one the the
scene where they're explaining how she
sees the future was it me that seemed
very like Ralph Bakshi a tease we're
drilling likes that which I like I mean
I like that a lot
um there are times we're watching this I
miss a river or Wibbly Boppity think
it's just Doctor Who um but there is
something about this show once in a
while it just sort of hit me with a
moment it's like like this one or that
moment and then the the fusion one where
I was like wow I kind of feel like a
little kid again watching it where it's
like kind of this real weird moment that
doesn't have an exact explanation it's
just sort of again there's it seems very
directed by just sort of mood and
emotion somehow and you know like
there's really no reason to show that
that's how she sees the future like that
have it go all black and the weird
colors and stuff and it just creates a
mood I kind of think you do need it
because this is still a kids show and a
visual representation oh no no no I
think it's not needed or it's not nice
I'm saying that you know you could have
said that or even
like just made projectile hologram that
show but having everything go black and
you see everything just and that's those
weird little triangle shades and
flipping around and doing that weird
stuff it's like it's nice I really think
it's cool and sort of like I say it
creates an atmosphere that really
reminds me of cavils old 80s
cartoons and movies um but the other
thing I like or what I got out of this
anyway is and I know a couple people
with anxiety and this is how they talk a
lot times like what if this happens
catapulting to the inevitable and yeah
well I mean I even that just like
they're so afraid of so much and on the
one hand it's you know you say you come
to a conclusion like they did in the in
the show and that's usually conclusion
they come to but it's kind of
understandable it's like yes you have
one life and really fucking anything can
take you out at any moment I mean you
never know what's imagine is right now
yeah I mean you don't go fuck I'll I
missed us um just hit the town over I
don't like that town it um
but what's it called Chicago and but
yeah it's one of those things where like
I think an episode like this is good
because it does show hey you know it's
just is part of living life you always
take the risk there's risks everywhere
but some point like you said well I
don't see much of a future for me up
here you know it's our life is taking
the risk but but his fear drove him like
it he worked himself into so many it was
like this circular thinking yeah it
worked himself into such a corner that
it became almost like it was basically a
self-fulfilling prophecy don't go up on
the roof well no matter what happens I'm
scared in this event so I'm gonna face
my fear I am gonna go up on the roof
yeah and then like you know but it's
it's one of those things where I don't
mean it literally over thought yeah it
is one of those things where I do think
like people that do so have this mindset
it's you know you can't always just say
no this happens duh I mean come on why
do you keep thinking this I mean it's
just it's a condition it's a way they
think and I think it takes a lot of time
to snap out of that um so it's what you
know there's the whole thing
prescription drugs yeah sure
but I think with all you know in this
episode we gets the message across I
mean I think anyone can become afraid of
a lot of things you know just out of
nowhere or after an incident or
something like that uh so when it
actually having part of it it's the
peril of knowing the future yeah you
know it's like going to the it's like
getting a kid getting a flu shot or
something half the time it's just easier
to surprise them with it and get it over
with quickly if you tell them the night
before then you're just thinking about
it yeah you know I remember when like
you used to have to get my blood work
drawn or like physical for school or
whatever like you know you'd be up the
night before like freaking out about it
ya know I go and you get it done then
you realize oh that wasn't that bad I
pretty much worked myself up into like
this fucking tizzy I don't know if I
very like I don't even know what the
qualification is whatever but like test
anxiety like I have to get my driver's
license renewed I have to do those
really simple easy written tests I mean
those are the easiest fucking things in
the world I am still like you know
pinata test attention test I mean I just
make a left hand turn do you a use your
Sigma topical oh yeah not using uh or C
Ram the person straight in front of you
see see oh no I did it again no it's one
of those things worried it's like but
just thinking about it I mean even now
it's like I know it'd be easy but one of
those things where it's just like you
know shit I just and it's like it does
feel like test anxiety even though I
don't shit man shit but just yeah and
when it's done it's like it like a
marijuana I was a younger even if I knew
I failed a test I was like okay by the
lease it's done at least I know the
failure is over with at least yeah at
least I had like a solid answer uh so I
mean I think everybody has like their
you know their thing that they can get
anxious about or afraid of that may be a
reasonable but eeeh can't help it um so
it's also a good episode for that though
I need if if only it was that simple for
you could just be like you know hey
knock it off okay and just it'd be done
you know um but it's still good to
always have those reminders and always
always be told and like hey that's just
part of it if you never went out did
anything nothing
Evon so um it's a good episode I think
again sort of with this with the way
we're raising I shouldn't say we're
raising but just with this generation
growing up I'm either does seem to be a
lot more worried and you know I mean we
always hear this stuff of a fucking
Halloween every year well okay like an
Hotel Transylvania 2 when they have the
vampire camp and like they don't let
anybody fail everybody wins and stuff
like that I mean do you say that
doesn't seem healthy but everybody's
happy everybody wins but that somehow
doesn't seem healthy I think something
like this is good because I think people
can get really fucking sensitive and
afraid of water and early on that they
suck know that they can suck I think
that's all it's the thing in my opinion
um you know but failures ok things I
gotta have the right side kind of yeah
of I mean it's one of those things and
it's it hurts and it and it does suck
but that's just part of it and you move
on and you live I mean if you protect
them from everything no like when we
were kids we would trick-or-treat in the
dark all the time yeah nowadays it's
done before some down I'm at the helm
here kid you know but um yeah so it's I
think this is a good episode for Cabot
generation because like you just don't
you don't know how sensitive so many
kids are gonna be or adults or parent or
it's now one of our ran so we're not
shitting on the next generation oh no
there's this place you're wrong with our
generation oh where to start
yeah no no I mean we're we're basically
going for a do Amex yeah we have totally
screwed you over
we're the reason there's no jobs out
there right now or we're like half the
reason let's be fair those baby boomers
start yeah it's gonna say it's probably
the bar very tart admission well we
didn't do shit about it one give a bunch
of it's it's all about peace and love to
you hit Wall Street wasn't it we create
technology to distract us how fucked up
and offer our world is becoming how
we're blowing it up but wow this got
like really but we were slacking off too
much to notice the world was going to
shit yeah that's like well there's no
jobs left um ok at least at least
iPhones are cheap well I did have a job
to begin with so sucks to be the next
gender
we're just gonna like us throwing my
flannel shirt listen to Nirvana and get
stoned like every generation they're
just born and then immediately thrown
until I go wish shelters it we just know
this is where you're going
um but yeah Wow sorry they got really
really pessimistic uh but bottom line
you should be afraid of everything cuz
it's totally how they after we just told
you how you should be afraid yes pretty
much so much semen yes sorry about that
so we're garnet I think so okay yeah we
just fucked everybody over the self a
little circle yeah full circle so um
sorry about that
uh I'm not I'm not either we're awesome
you're fine